a little bit on the importance of
telling the truth and who better than
Jordan Peterson
the consequences of not saying what was
true is like whatever hell you might
fall into by opening your mouth when you
have something to say that isn't popular
it's nothing like the hell that you're
going to envelop yourself in if you lose
control of your own tongue and mind and
I like I said in my clinical practice I
never saw anyone get away with anything
even once and so all you have in a
situation like that is what is the truth
now you know of course you only have
your approximations to the truth but
that's better than nothing you need to
be afraid of the right thing and you
should be afraid of contaminating your
soul with deceit that's what you should
be afraid of that will definitely do you
in and I know exactly how what happens
is
you know garbage in garbage out the old
programmers saying goes and so you'll
fill your head with nonsense and no one
will call you on it except you but you
can steal that voice if you try hard
enough you just wait until you get in
real trouble
you can't get away with it one way or
another right like the endless line or
the not saying what you know to be true
because you think you can skirt around
it or you'll Escape or just you take the
easy way out
um that's why I'm curious for those of
you that are supporting Trump through
all of the lies and by the way
please if Ron DeSantis or the campaign
just starts relentlessly lying about
everything Trump Biden Florida blah blah
if I don't call it out call Nia right
like that's the best we can do that's
the best we can do but are you okay with
the destruction of Truth in the quest
for power that would be my question for
Donald Trump right now I just want to
play one other short video this is Carl
Sagan I've mentioned Carl Sagan a bunch
of times on the show I think we've shown
one or two clips of him over the years
he was the incredible astronomer and
science Communicator professor at
Cornell University he wrote the book
Cosmos was really his most ubiquitous
book that then became the incredible
science series that was on American
television I think late 70s early 80s
what many of you might know him from was
the incredible movie it's one of my top
three favorite movies of all time is
only work of fiction was the movie
contact with Jody Foster and Matthew
McConaughey just an absolutely
absolutely wonderful movie if you
haven't seen it actually at the
beginning of covid we were doing movie
Nights with the locals community and we
all watched that one together and then
talked about it after uh anyway here he
is uh he's long since passed but here he
is talking about why we should not
suppress ideas and what the path to
knowledge really is all about
suppression of uncomfortable ideas may
be common in religion or in politics but
it is not the path to knowledge and
there's no place for it in the Endeavor
of science
all right so the path to knowledge I get
it politicians lie
I get it people from the media lie but
as we are seeing so many lives
disintegrate in front of our eyes right
like the long list of Lies Donald Trump
very fine people on both sides Brett
Kavanaugh is a serial rapist Russia
collusion this that the other thing well
then maybe it's incumbent on us to try
to get out of this with something that's
true and I think that that's where Trump
is sort of caught right now okay they're
all liars but the way to get out of
their lying Abyss is not through lies
it's through truth that's how you'll
build something that'll get us out of
the quicksand
I think that's what we got to do
and as I always say I don't think I'm
the only one
[Music]